[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst and uh the former NFL offensive
lineman has a podcast called even money
a betting podcast are you any good at uh
gambling or giving gambling advice
you know what Dan I actually am pretty
decent at it I've been doing it now for
seven or eight years thank goodness that
I started this it's funny because I
started the Ross Tucker football podcast
like 10 years ago and then all my
buddies all they did was talk about
fantasy football so I started a fantasy
Feast podcast and then several of them
all they did was talk about betting I
don't know where they were doing it or
whether or not it was legal when they
were doing that but so I started the
even money betting podcast and of course
that's like the most popular one now and
I do pretty well yeah now my co-host
Steve fezik is a professional better in
Vegas he's the two-time winner of the
super contest so he typically does
better than me uh but we're both very
much in the black over the years I'm
having a better year than him so far
this year though
how aware of the point spread were you
when you played
not very
like almost not at all
and to the point where the only time I
ever thought about it was when maybe a
coach brought it up as disrespectful
although I will say this Dan my uh I
don't know why but when I was a freshman
at Princeton okay 97
they had betting lines for the ivy
league games I don't know if they still
do or not so my first game were playing
at Cornell and I'm on the punt team and
the field goal team and that week my dad
calls me up and he says hey Ross if I
give you the signal let your guy block
the point
I was like what and so he told me he was
joking obviously but he told me what the
spread was for the game and I guess
or whatever bet on Ivy League yeah so
but it is crazy Dan I'm 18 years I just
turned 18 in March just had my prom it's
like August or September it is wild at
the time to think about like wait a
minute there are people wagering money
on whether or not I blocked I never even
been on the punt team before whether or
not I blocked this guy on punt like
there's people that determines their
money it was it was actually made me
think a lot back in 1997 kind of wild
Seton give Ross the poll question from
hour one and see how he'd respond
biggest winner this weekend your uh
options are Brian Kelly Robert Sala uh
Georgia football
Justin Fields Marcus Freeman or Geno
Smith
biggest winner or if you want to add to
that list
yeah
um
I I think the first two jumped out to me
I I think it's Brian Kelly and Marcus
Freeman you know college football is so
interesting where it's like you really
need that signature win especially at
home and people you know can sustain
that for a year or two just based on
that so Brian Keller getting a win over
Alabama in his first year is gigantic
they never beat Alabama only the one Joe
burrow year and then for Freeman they've
had some bad losses I mean you lose to
Marshall you lose to Stanford he needed
that in the worst way for Notre Dame
fans to feel better about him as a head
coach I feel like as a player you know
Justin Fields is obviously ascending
Geno Smith's one of the most incredible
stories of the year and I absolutely
love it but players I feel like are
almost a little bit more on a week to
week and it's not as much of a signature
win as it is for a college coach I mean
those guys will both be at their
respective schools like two more years
now and I'm in I know it's their first
year but two more years at a minimum
just because the fan remember when they
beat Clemson though remember when he
beat Alabama that's the way college
football rolls
now the poll question for hour two see
the flip side of that with the all due
respect option uh Biggest Loser this
weekend the Raiders Nick Saban Aaron
Rodgers the city of Philadelphia uh
Cliff Kingsbury or the Rams
I think it's Aaron Rodgers actually I I
think it's Aaron Rodgers that was the
worst football game I've ever seen him
play I actually asked on Twitter at Ross
Tucker NFL there's a worse game he never
throws like red zone or end zone
interceptions he had three
and all three were a thousand percent
his fault all three were terrible throws
he even missed an open receiver on a
deep post where he threw the ball late
and it got batted down so worse asking
him play they're three and six they're
not going in the playoffs this is
probably his last year in Green Bay this
is how it will end for him which isn't
well Rashaan Gary's done for the year if
I talk to David bakhtiari who's out of
the game again with his knee I would
tell him my person if he was my brother
I would tell him never play football
again it's a bad it's a mess right now
in Green Bay and it's gonna end up
ending it feels like really really
poorly for him there here's a number for
you uh in 2020 and 2021 Aaron Rodgers
had 377 pass attempts against NFC North
teams
zero interceptions
in the first 36 minutes of the game on
Sunday 23 pass attempts
three interceptions against the Lions
that's amazing
amazing that's a crazy stat uh you know
I don't have that much
sympathy for his situation Dan because
he wasn't there all off season right
like now I don't know what happened with
Devonte Adams evidently he and Derek
Carr are good friends do I think Devonte
Adams would have left Green Bay if Tom
Brady was the quarterback of the Packers
no I don't think he would have I think
Devonta has probably still being Green
Bay but that's neither here nor there
yeah but do you think he left because of
Rogers or do you think he left because
of his friendship with Derek Carr
I think he left because of his
friendship with Derek Carr I think his
relationship with the Packers and or
Rogers wasn't enough to be able to sway
or compel him to stay like
I feel this is just my perception right
Dan I think Rogers and Devonte Adams
probably had a conversation and Devonte
said look I grew up a Raiders fan you
know Green Bay's messing with me with
the money I I want to go out but didn't
they offer him more money than the
Raiders did
eventually at the end all right but I
think it had gone up I think it had gone
a bad way when they had kind of
lowballed him earlier but in my this is
just a perception I have no inside
information but I feel like Rogers would
probably be like you know what man I get
it I get it you know best of luck to you
whereas having played with Brady I feel
like Brady Dan would have been like the
hell you are no you're not and like
convince Devante to stay and put the
full court press on and make it
unacceptable for him to leave I I just
feel like they're very different
personalities he's Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst host of the
Ross Tucker football podcast give me the
teams that are done that might surprise
people that you think well you mentioned
Green Bay Green Bay's not making the
playoffs right they got Dallas coming to
town next weekend see if they beat
Dallas then all of a sudden hey four and
six you're not going to win the division
because of the Vikings but the NFC is
kind of like top heavy
but so Green Bay's not making the
playoffs according to you right yeah I
think they're done all right and I know
people say well how are you gonna get
seven teams well right now it looks like
there's three teams from the NFC East
and with the way they're playing and
then I think the NFC West gets to I I
think you know the Niners the way they
played their last game out I'd be
surprised if they don't get nine or ten
wins do you think the Rams the Packers
are making the playoffs are the Rams
making the playoffs no I think they're
done as well yeah I think I think it's I
think they're a lot you know Dan if the
Bucks had lost yesterday
I think they still could have won the
NFC South potentially but the Rams
losing the way in which they lost now
they're looking way up at both the
Seahawks and the Niners it's kind of
crazy because I think the the Rams and
the Packers are both as close to done as
you can be in whatever we are just
finishing up week nine Raiders are done
yeah and and then look I'm not here to
kill Josh McDaniels at all
but I don't understand why they ever got
rid of bisaccia I mean it was his only
sample size as a head coach
it was after the Henry rugs incident it
was after all the Gruden emails he gets
the job Midway through they win all
those close games they get to the
playoffs even in the playoff game there
are cars on the goal line against the
Bengals they almost won that they almost
beat the Bengals who went to the Super
Bowl I guess I don't understand the
logic Dan if you're Mark Davis maybe
Versace is not the guy maybe you give
him a three-year deal and if it goes
poorly you fire him after one but the
only sample size for versacea as a head
coach in the NFL was really really good
the only sample size we had for
McDaniels is the head coach in the NFL
in Denver was terrible so the idea to
just get rid of mayak and versacea and
bring in McDaniels I don't know who got
that in Mark Davis's head or if it
wasn't his head but it's been a disaster
I mean the Raiders season has been an
absolute three games you're up by 17
points or more and you lose yeah on some
level that's coaching
yeah I just wonder you know Denver a lot
of people like them as a dark horse to
be a Super Bowl Contender certainly
playoffs they seem to be done
um anybody else that you would throw in
the mix that uh
well obviously but I think we already
know that Cardinals
um the Chargers have this not only do
the Chargers play the same game every
week Dan they have the same season every
season I know can you imagine me the
Chargers are like watching that pretty
decent but not great movie over and over
and over again
yeah like Sex In The City the movie
it's not any good but people still watch
it over not that I do but people
have you watched Sex In The City the
movie I have not watched Sex In The City
the movie I don't think but I watched
the show a decent amount because when my
wife and I were dating
she was living in New York you know 2001
to 2006 I was Washington Dallas Buffalo
and that was like the hot show at the
time I liked um I liked the brunette
what's her name Kristen Davis yeah yeah
that was yeah that would have been like
if you're asking me which one of these I
wasn't I was about to call them the
housewives that I would have picked that
would have been my that was the one I
like I liked her segments although I
like the attitude of the blonde one I
like the mentality of the older blonde
one Kim cattrell
yes I liked her mentality but I liked uh
the brunette in terms of appearance
Sarah Jessica Parker never did that much
for me either way and she was always
like pondering stuff and oh I don't know
what to do should I go with Mr Big or
like the to do with the hair wasn't into
that it wasn't a Sarah Jessica Parker
this is why next year you're winning the
award I know you're in the Hall of Fame
now but this is why next year you guys
are winning the Emmy you need to submit
the last three minutes we're getting it
this year the heck with good morning
football they can't hold a candle to
those last three minutes I met some guy
over the weekend and uh he said you know
why you don't win the sports enemy and I
go no he goes well you don't talk sports
and I said oh okay and he goes I mean
that as a compliment that uh you know to
win the sports Emmy you got to talk
sports and I thought oh okay what a
novel approach here no I just lost
whatever you're doing you're doing it
right every time I'm in an airport at
least one person will say to me I'm a
big fan and I'll always be like oh is it
my podcast is it me on on calling the
games for CBS or what they're like no no
Dan Patrick's show you know I'm like my
guest segment or like the three times a
year I fill in yeah that's it okay cool
who I'll take it who labeled you the
Meathead James Vander Beek
uh was that one of my listeners Paulie I
think either one of the listeners or
Paul I don't think Paulie would say
something like that I wish I could take
credit for that it was it was definitely
a caller so Meathead James Vander Beek
which by the way I like it's so funny
Dan when people call me a meathead I
think they want me to be like offended
like as long as you say ivy league
Meathead I'm fine with that you know I
went to the best school in the country
but I appreciate the Finer Things in
Life beer food you know talking about
football Sarah Jessica Parker every once
in a while what's wrong with that Sex in
the City yeah all Sex in the City
Kristen Davis with controls mentality
and mindset exactly
foreign
I look forward to it you got an action
tomorrow night don't you tomorrow night
my third game in the last six days I did
Texans uh Eagles Thursday night for
Westwood I did San Diego State UNLV
Saturday night and tomorrow night Dan I
want everyone to take their duty to the
country seriously
tomorrow on Election Day and watch
Eastern Michigan at Akron 7 P.M on CBS
Sports Network
okay
that's their Duty that's the joke
forget going to the polls make sure you
watch don't be watching because they
don't know who wins until like midnight
anyway seven to ten thirty Eastern
Michigan Akron maxion's hilarious it's
amazing I love it it's Tuesday night I
and you know what they did a great job
marketing that you get a standalone game
and people will watch if this game was
over the weekend date you wouldn't get
any audience but then you would be
amazed how many tweets and how many text
messages I will get tomorrow night I'll
get text messages from like NFL head
coaches or GMS just because they get
home or they have it on in the
background it's it's genius which by the
way Dan my idea okay
somebody needs to play a Saturday
morning 10 a.m game I've told Paulie and
the danets this
Saturday you know maybe it's the ivy
league maybe it's uh like the CAA UNH in
Delaware and Richmond and whatever there
if there's a game Saturday morning
people would watch it hey by the way I
had my source who told me this over the
weekend San Diego State getting ready to
join the Pac-12
that is a rumor yes that is a room it
was going to happen they would probably
make the announcement this week but
that that would not surprise me you know
Dan after the Padres they're the second
biggest thing in town they got a brand
new stadium San Diego is an awesome City
they have the stadium Marshall Faulk was
there it's right where Qualcomm was I
mean if you're the Pac-12 and you're
looking to add San Diego State's a
pretty obvious ad uh safe travels always
great to talk to you thank you Ross
absolutely see you Dan that's Ross
Tucker he's got a betting podcast called
even money and of course the Ross Tucker
football podcast